favoriser la compréhension et la
transmission de l'histoire par une
plongée au coeur des cultures c'est ce
que fait chaque année le collectif pour
la semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé
de saint quentin en yvelines organisée
depuis 2009 la journée au port en
hommage à tous ceux qui ont combattu
contre l'esclavagé et ses séquelles
quand les jambes sont connaissent bien
l'histoire quand les gens comprennent un
peu c'est que les gens ressentent à
travers ce témoin là on espère que c'est
jacky et comportements pourquoi cette
attitude raciste du lit du racisme ont
pris ces dix on allait en diminuant
notre but c'est d'apprendre et de
partager avec vous tout le monde pour
mieux vivre ensemble au programme un
marché tropicale avec une vente de
produits artisanaux un stand de
maquillage une tombola et surtout une
exposition phare la fraude autour en
stands représentant 11 pays étaient
présents on va visiter l'afrique les
caraïbes l'amérique est vraiment
l'objectif c'est de faire découvrir aux
enfants et aux plus grands aussi les
différents pays où il qu'on a envie de
mettre en avant et tout leur patrimoine
justement culturels ou historiques
donc on a un peu revisiter des
classiques comme de twister par exemple
qu'on adapte et on a aussi revisité par
exemple des pièces pour justement faire
découvrir des personnages d'haïti tous
les stands dans le marché on est la
piste c'est à dire voilà un panneau qui
présente à un artiste en fait c'est une
forme de dommages à ces artistes de la
la il s'agit déjà et jacob desvarieux
cli et le créateur du zouk une journée
d'échangé de partage qui célèbre la loi
taubira le 10 mai 2001 la france est
devenue le premier pays au monde à
reconnaître la traite négrière et
l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité